- [Instructor] You've
likely heard the concept
of even and odd numbers,
and what we're going to do
in this video is think about
even and odd functions.
And as you can see or as you will see,
there's a little bit of a
parallel between the two,
but there's also some differences.
So let's first think about
what an even function is.
One way to think about
an even function is that
if you were to flip it over the y-axis,
that the function looks the same.
So here's a classic example
of an even function.
It would be this right over here,
your classic parabola
where your vertex
is on the y-axis.
This is an even function.
So this one is maybe the graph
of f of x is equal to x squared.
And notice, if you were to
flip it over the y-axis,
you're going to get the exact same graph.
Now, a way that we can talk
about that mathematically,
and we've talked about this
when we introduced the idea of reflection,
to say that a function is equal
to its reflection over the y-axis,
that's just saying that f of
x is equal to f of negative x.
Because if you were to replace
your x's with a negative x,
that flips your function over the y-axis.
Now, what about odd functions?
So odd functions, you
get the same function
if you flip over the y- and the x-axes.
So let me draw a classic
example of an odd function.
Our classic example would be
f of x is equal to x to the third,
is equal to x to the third,
and it looks something like this.
So notice, if you were to
flip first over the y-axis,
you would get something
that looks like this.
So I'll do it as a dotted line.
If you were to flip just over the y-axis,
it would look like this.
And then if you were to
flip that over the x-axis,
well, then you're going to
get the same function again.
Now, how would we write
this down mathematically?
Well, that means that our
function is equivalent to
not only flipping it over the y-axis,
which would be f of negative x,
but then flipping that over the x-axis,
which is just taking the negative of that.
So this is doing two flips.
So some of you might be noticing a pattern
or think you might be on the
verge of seeing a pattern
that connects the words even
and odd with the notions
that we know from earlier
in our mathematical lives.
I've just shown you an even function
where the exponent is an even number,
and I've just showed you an odd function
where the exponent is an odd number.
Now, I encourage you to try
out many, many more polynomials
and try out the exponents,
but it turns out that if you
just have f of x is equal to,
if you just have f of x
is equal to x to the n,
then this is going to be an
even function if n is even,
and it's going to an odd
function if n is odd.
So that's one connection.
Now, some of you are thinking,
"Wait, but there seem
to be a lot of functions
"that are neither even nor odd."
And that is indeed the case.
For example, if you just had
the graph x squared plus two,
this right over here is
still going to be even.
'Cause if you flip it over,
you have the symmetry around the y-axis.
You're going to get back to itself.
But if you had x minus two squared,
which looks like this,
x minus two, that would
shift two to the right,
it'll look like that.
That is no longer even.
Because notice, if you
flip it over the y-axis,
you're no longer getting
the same function.
So it's not just the exponent.
It also matters on the structure
of the expression itself.
If you have something very
simple, like just x to the n,
well, then that could be or
that would be even or odd
depending on what your n is.
Similarly, if we were
to shift this f of x,
if we were to even shift
it up, it's no longer,
it is no longer, so if
this is x to the third,
let's say, plus three,
this is no longer odd.
Because you flip it over once,
you get right over there.
But then you flip it again,
you're going to get this.
You're going to get something like this.
So you're no longer back
to your original function.
Now, an interesting thing to think about,
can you imagine a function
that is both even and odd?
So I encourage you to pause that video,
or pause the video and
try to think about it.
Is there a function where f of
x is equal to f of negative x
and f of x is equal to the
negative of f of negative x?
Well, I'll give you a hint,
or actually I'll just give you the answer.
Imagine if f of x is just
equal to the constant zero.
Notice, this thing is
just a horizontal line,
just like that, at y is equal to zero.
And if you flip it over the y-axis,
you get back to where it was before.
Then if you flip it over the x-axis,
again, then you're still back
to where you were before.
So this over here is both even and odd,
a very interesting case.